if there was only one podcast in the  world who would you want the two  co-hosts to be  um i think a great  podcast would be  um  biden and trump that would be great if  they were forced to podcast together  wouldn't it be funny if they turned out  to have like electric chemistry if it  was just that would be hilarious  hi i'm joe and i'm donald and this is  two sides to the coin yeah it's like are  you debate points and then yeah it  actually works out well yeah you could  do like a good betting thing it's like  will biden make it to the fifth episode  will trump get arrested before episode  seven it would be kind of like a podcast  on the run that would be a great one  that would be a good one yeah